[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis hop step i'm constantine kisum
and this is to show you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest this week is
a returning guest to trigonometry he's a
youtuber
sargon of akkad Karl Bentham and welcome
back thanks for having me we do you
appreciate it it's good - how are you
handling the vise are you self isolating
I imagine yeah but I honestly work from
home my office is in my garage so
honestly my daily life is exactly the
same I didn't realize a business Oh face
something for the past like five years
yeah you've pioneered the whole movement
well it's interesting times and one of
the things I was thinking obviously you
you and us as well we spent a lot of
time in the last few years talking about
the culture war you know it seems to me
that you know like when people are dying
of coronavirus when there's a shortage
of ventilators somehow what pronouns you
use has become slightly less important
do you do you get that sense why it's
it's inevitable really isn't it concerns
about things like racism and sexism and
trigger warnings and pronouns are all
very much that they're the kind of apex
of first world problems like very minor
feelings that can be blown out of
proportion by people who have an
interest in doing that sort of thing but
as soon as suddenly it's like well you
might not have food you might get sick
with a terrible illness and die suddenly
these things just naturally take a
backseat I I guess the woke brigade are
desperately praying that civilization
doesn't collapse
so they can continue whining about
mourning other words were using frankly
because otherwise they've got some
problems of my faith but even even like
we were talking about just now that fact
actually it seems to be receding we
don't have these conversations as much
we're still having one particular
conversation and that is whether to call
the coronavirus the Wu Han virus or the
China virus and is it in fact racist to
do so because
people think it is where do you stand on
that I'm going to get a takeaway that's
that's ridiculous no one thinks that
it's tied to ethnicity what they're
saying is that this is just the naming
convention of the area or group of
people upon which it first reaches
public prominence and sort of enters
into the mainstream narrative business
like Ebola is what as a river in Africa
isn't it I think it should represent
Congo
yeah River in the Congo yeah you've got
Middle Eastern respiratory syndrome and
things like that it's no one complains
then you know no one complains a Spanish
food because it's not a judgement but I
suppose that the I suppose there's a bit
of resentment because perhaps in the
case of like saying the Chinese artists
there is a judgement because I mean I'm
sure you guys have looked into these wet
markets in China since all of this yeah
they do seem a little unsanitary and
[Laughter]
Valley the cultural practice that might
be valid to criticize and and we think
is you know it's how many of the same
kind it's the reason that it's worth
actually calling it something other than
just coronaviruses coronaviruses a
category in viruses i didn't know all of
this before but but basically there are
lots of different kinds of current
viruses and a lot of them have come from
China probably due to these unsanitary
conditions like SARS bird flu and swine
plane yeah swine flu the Black Death
came from China as well probably in the
similar conditions so I think there's
probably a conversation to be had like
can I can I just stop you there I think
we should refer it to in the modern it's
2020 we should refer to as the plague of
color well I think I think the technical
term should be the blue hand flu virus
communicates specific you know because
they're like said there there are other
Chinese viruses but I can see why
Trump's calling you the Chinese virus
and I can't believe that the Chinese
Communist Party allowed it to provoke
them I can't believe it's something
they've tried firing back on like China
is an awful state like the state the the
government of China a genuine fascist
they've got you know a million
and concentration camps they've got
these social credit systems that utterly
tyrannical they don't have free breasts
they don't have free moves they they
have a command economy I mean it really
does look like a fascist government if
you just toss out all the things they're
doing and so mean
are we taking moral instruction from the
Chinese Communist Party I don't think we
are well I think this is why Trump has
started calling it that the Chinese
coronavirus because he sees it as a kind
of warfare situation where the Chinese
are trying to create this idea that the
US Army came up with this thing and and
and also the reality is that as far as
we know China is responsible not only
the web markets but they suppress the
information that could have allowed
other people to prepare better and the
people people are dying around Europe
and the rest of the world because of
that and actually what that's probably
one of the things that will change
fundamentally and we'll talk more about
other things that will change but our
relationship with China is going to be
completely different when this is over
isn't it well I I would hope so I think
a lot of people have been thinking out
of sight out of mind when it comes to
China but I mean one of the one of the
consequences of outsourcing our
industrial capacity to China I mean you
know it was appealing because they could
throw infinite amounts of sweatshop
labor the things we wanted to to make it
to buy so we could buy all of this stuff
dirt cheap but I mean nothing's you know
everything comes with a price and the
price that we've had to pay in this
regard is that China now is the second
largest economy and it's headed by a
communist party a one-party totalitarian
dictatorship where the the Zi Jinping
has just given himself executive powers
for life so it's it's one of those like
you know this was quite a high price to
pay and I think that they're going to
sacrifice a lot of a lot of things that
we might consider things that shouldn't
be sacrificed before they they change
their ways and so I think that some I
think we've really got to rethink it I
mean I personally would prefer a more
sort of a and I don't lose word populist
populist but I I can out my coming about
ways and essentially we we should have a
kind of social understanding that you
don't buy from China
I know it sounds strange but I mean we
should really pretty [ __ ] hard right
now the problem is yeah it's massively
hard yeah but I do think like like with
the climate change stuff and they can
demand like you know in Sweden though
demanding and climate dictatorship and
things like this but at the end of the
day I think that the the general ethos
will filter into the popular
consciousness
I think people so well I'd rather buy
you know I mean I you know where I can I
buy you know free-range eggs right I
don't like battery farming so I do my
plants my free-range eggs because I can
afford it admittedly but like you know
the the I think that these these things
are these the demand does create the
change in the market I think that's
something that we can do it's at least
something that the individual can do on
their personal I'm saying right do I
need this cheap tat from China probably
not you know could I buy a more
expensive version made somewhere else
yes I probably could maybe I should do
that you know I mean maybe we can
actually make the world a better place
slightly by degree and but yeah I I
really would like to rethink the
relationship with China because it was
foolish to allow them to essentially buy
up all of the jobs that we thought we
didn't want to do so it's hollowed out
the West anyway you know I think the
main the main crisis that brought
President Trump I think was the loss of
this kind of social ladder that was
manufacturing jobs and practical jobs
because there's this arrogance about
academia I think and the middle class
when they think well the only way that
you can be smart and successful is if
you go to university so you get everyone
to go to university but some people just
don't learn academically some people
learn through doing using their hands
you know and then any less smart than
anyone else it's just a different way of
viewing the world interacting with the
world you know it's more concrete less
conceptual and it seems arrogant to say
yeah no [ __ ] you guys you can just join
us in the in the smarty pants area but
you can get down and read the books you
know I mean I know lots of my family who
are very much in the category that I'm
talking about and they're they are not
academics it's just not what they're
about you know but they are hardworking
and they are smart and they can get
things done and I think that we we could
we could at least have you know give a
bit of ear to these people a bit of
consideration
but but these are the Gammons so why
would we you know the racist i swear to
god one of the difficulties with doing
these videos remotely now instead of in
studios we did the last time as the
francis now looks like the most Kameny
person and he's actually called us
lovely shade of gammon talked to in
particular about trump because initially
he was criticized about his response to
the virus the way that he was dealing
with it and you know and a lot of sound
criticisms there but he seems to have
changed the debate whether it's racist
to called it the china virus and in fact
somebody told me the other day that one
of his cabinet could beat the come flu
he's has Trump rather re skillful really
really skillfully reframe the debate
from his own approach to it to actually
this debate which isn't important in any
shape or form I think the I think the
debate that isn't important in any shape
or form is essentially a red herring to
throw off the the sort of world karate
who are going to get their knickers in a
twist about this because if you look at
what Trump's doing it seems to actually
be pretty good generally even if now
you've got a remember that Trump is an
entity right he said he's a political
entity and he has known qualities and
defined boundaries and you know some of
these known qualities are him being
brash and boorish and some of her
boundaries are you know the limits of
his ability to articulate but he's also
got over here and he has virtues as well
as much as a lot of people don't want to
admit it and one of the things I think
him and Boris have done which is
actually really sensible is the daily or
almost daily briefings and they've been
doing just this you know streamed on the
internet played on TV and because the
there is a concern that leadership like
the people at the top need to show level
right and this is this is the leadership
cause II now Trump might say everything
he does is the best and they have the
best things at all times but it is also
a kind of reassuring regularity becomes
the normal right to have you know the
the you know the president get up and
even if you don't like him he sits there
and says well look you know here's an
expert here here's an expert here these
what these experts are gonna say this is
what we're doing you know we're doing
our best this is a surprise it's been
sprung enough because you said you know
Trump was criticized for not doing
enough now it's like yeah he's gonna
criticize they are really pathological
when it comes to their criticisms of
Trump and so I'm just like okay what you
know what's he actually doing and
they've the currently trying to put this
two billion dollar package through so
that Americans will get money tax
rebates and businesses will continue to
exist so once this has passed people
will have jobs to go back to it appears
that it's actually the Democrats were
blocking this and Trump signed all off
on all that it was his Treasury that was
demanding that there was money being
given to people and I mean like I'm off
letting you look at my own this sounds
like something Bernie Sanders would do
right this you know to give people money
I'm a liberal I'm not a socialist and so
I'm certainly thinking okay I mean you
know needs must as the devil drives but
I you know that strikes me as being a
very light I think it's the sole
precedent that could either go really
well or really badly you know so I'm
kind of hoping that it goes really well
and not really badly but you can see the
position that they're in and for some
reason the Democrats are blocking this
so I mean I don't really know what Trump
is supposed to be doing because he's not
a dictator there's a lot of devolved
power in the United States and by design
so I mean you know like Cuomo shutting
down New York it looks really reasonable
given what New York is in a massive
epicenter of people and Commerce and
traffic and stuff but if you're in the
Midwest sort of thing and for example
like here I'm in the southwest of
England showing down London totally
makes sense but I mean social gatherings
and pubs fine
but there are still loads of people on
the streets here everything seems to be
fairly normal nobodies you know we've
had very very few incidents of this
virus so everyone's kind of going about
their day as if it's a day
but Germany I don't think he's done a
bad job so far I don't know what
everyone's expecting what we want him to
do and one thing I'm wary of is this
kind of continental style lockdown I
think the the distinction between what
we and the United States have done and
Canada as well and in fact New Zealand's
only just like them as well compared to
the speed of it on the continent I
think's the tip I think it speaks to two
different mindsets and the the
english-speaking world tends to have a
kind of you need to be responsible you
know the government isn't your daddy you
need to be responsible and so you know
we should be personally more responsible
I don't really want the police to come
out and check my papers for going down
to those shops but in return for that
freedom I'm not going to be responsible
and go down the shops especially if I
feel sick so yeah it's interesting I
used to office Lee I grew up on a
society where the police would check
your papers but they wouldn't check it
on your way to the shops because the
shop store was [ __ ] empty just like
Francis they're growing up and for parts
of his life in Venezuela but what do you
what do you make about of what's
happening you mentioned the UK it's
interesting that you talk about that
steady reassurance because my wife is
completely apolitical
she watched Boris Johnson address to the
nation yesterday and she said oh I
thought he actually did really well
whereas whenever David Cameron used to
appear on TV she used to instantly have
to halt suppress and vomit she just
thought that guy is so fake so there's
something about Boris and particularly
hid the way that he's handling this you
know he's lost all the you know he
hasn't referenced the Greek tragedy for
weeks now he's got out the jokes you
know what I mean like he's taken it
seriously what do you make of how we
handle this because you say you're a
liberal and he is clearly someone who
who tried to have the most careful
response to this in the sense that he
didn't want to impose draconian
sanctions or hands-off right but but I
think we can all see that that didn't
work I mean people were not responding
the way that you would want well I mean
like I'm never I'm never excited about
the exercise of state power really in
any regard it's not something I'd like
to see I like to see some spontaneous
action by people living their lives but
I mean it can be warranted in certain
circumstances obviously no during World
War two it's completely warranted the
effectively everyone had to be on the
same team and this seems to be a crisis
of fair magnitude so I don't think that
what they're doing is necessarily
unwarranted at all and I think I I don't
I don't think it's gonna get too silly
either to be honest I don't think that
the police are gonna you know be like
right well you know that's it Boris I
said inside so inside if there are some
kids playing on the grass and I think
it's gonna be like no I think that will
weather the worst what else we can do
guy that's a I think your point about
them being level-headed is actually
quite good and the same goes for Trump
as well you know they're very eccentric
people Barris and Trump in their own
rights and but I think that they have
taken the right tone that it looks like
they're concerned and like when they
first started doing the press
conferences they look exhausted
you know they look they look really
tired so you know to me as you know I
mean III you know I think they did a
half decent job but to me it just looked
like they've been working all night you
know before they came and gave their
announcements and I think in a way
that's reassuring I think people need to
see that they are taking it seriously
they're not being frivolous and flippant
and you know we just have to pull
together I guess you know as the Blitz
spirit as they say and Kyle there seems
to be this interesting phenomena it's
particularly amongst a left where they
seem to be wanting to get ever more
authoritarian and you see it with some
of their comments with some of their
commentary on line do you agree with
that I can guess you don't by what you
said before and more importantly why do
you think that is I think this this this
is most evident in the proposed bill
that Nancy Pelosi put up instead of
agreeing to the bill drafted by the
Republicans which like I said the bills
offered by the Republicans effectively a
Democrat bill it looked very very very
friendly to their positions but instead
they the bill Pelosi promoted was loaded
with woke
frankly loaded with all of their pet
projects so you know like further
political grabs on unlike you know
healthcare environment diversity quotas
and information but making and making
mandatory that every company and every
government agency have to give over the
diversity information that's like well
there's only one reason why they're ever
going to need that information and
that's so they can say well that
company's racist all that sexist or
whatever you know that's the only reason
they never asked and and so this this
like weird power grab is annoying but I
think it's because honestly the I mean
if foods are boiled down on the left and
the right to being sort of they mean the
left seem to have a particular desire
for order and central planning and if
we're gonna say the right is the sort of
libertarian types who people who want
constitutional government and that's the
only way I can frame what far-right is
because I think if they thought I was a
Nazi they just call me a Nazi they said
they'd call me far-right and I'm like
okay well I want constitutional order
limited government on personal
independence so if that's the the the
opposite well then they're going to
naturally push towards more state
control in order to create a more
perfect system and I think that the
imperfections are kind of inevitable
it's interesting isn't it because I
think the desire for it is actually
probably something that just both the
political extremes want there are people
on what you might actually accurately
describe as the far right who also want
order mass deportations you know an
authoritarian government as well so I
think it's actually just what it really
reveals is that while being an actual
far-right person is completely
unacceptable in in civil society in the
public square being a far left person is
not only acceptable you're actually
welcomed you you get invited on question
time etc well yeah I mean I'm very
dubious about calling the fascists far
right to be honest I've been about this
a lot and I just don't see what the
definition of far-right we're using that
could make them and say you know all the
sort of end cap types you know the beat
the anti state trappers who you know to
want the government to leave them alone
how do they fit into the same box and I
really don't think they do and and I
think that there's a I think honestly
the far left has been deliberate about
trying to portray them as far right
because I think they're a lot closer to
the left than they are to the right
frankly all of the fascists were
communists first or socialists first and
if it's it's a natural evolution of the
socialist philosophy because the the
Socialists effectively Marx wants
revolution of the proletariat they seize
the means of production they create
their temporary dictatorship of the
proletariat and then whatever glorious
leader and they implements real
socialism and that for some reason fades
away over time into a stateless
classless propertyless moneyless society
the the fashion is son Mussolini in
Giovanni Gentilly just openly said well
socialism is a dead doctrine it doesn't
work you know that's not gonna happen
however we could take over everything
and perfect the state entirely we're not
gonna get rid of the state we're gonna
turn the state into essentially our
model for God you know provides you know
nothing against the state nothing
outside of the state formulation you
know the state becomes God effectively
and so I don't think that you can draw a
straight line from liberalism to fascism
but you'd have to go through socialism
and communism first and I think that's
why China's Communist Party just looks a
lot like Nazi Germany at this point I
think that the there are kind of a
series of incentives and necessities
that you end up falling through whether
you like it or not you know well sorry
France I just want to finish one so but
I think when we talk about the evolution
I mean there is a evolution from what
you might describe as conservatives and
conserves and being the desire for order
for cleanliness for homogeneity etc
right so when we talk about that being
the right I'm not talking about the
ancap and whatever and the libertarian
right but perhaps the conservative right
people who if you take that to its
extreme branch you end up perhaps on
what has conventionally been described
as the far right which is the kind of
white nationalist
Nazi type way of thinking yeah I mean
with all of these things the turn left
and right is not really very useful no
no this this is why I'm specifically
naming ideologies and trying to
essentially connect the narrative of how
they came about and what they led to and
the reason they led to these things
because then I think you have a more
sensible structure of like where people
sit in this little tree of ideology and
because essentially all of these things
came out of the Enlightenment and then
you've got like sake at the cathode
Catholic tradition isms or thing it's an
entire separate branch you know it's
it's not an environment ideal it comes
from the Bible it comes from theocracy
it comes from tradition and so it's it's
got a different set of values and they
can end up looking very similar you're
absolutely right but I just I just hate
using terms left and right because this
doesn't mean anything like a fascist is
so far away from the sort of like
liberal libertarian time even though you
know they get lumped into the same box
and I just I don't think it's very
useful but some but anyway I'd like I
think I think fascism has been
successfully discredited at this point I
think the twentieth century has done a
number on it and I mean you would have
thought the same would have happened for
communism to but essentially the next
thing we have to do is discredit
communism and hopefully we can just
hover around a kind of realistic
liberalism and just kind of a liberalism
that's interesting dealing with the
facts as they are because a lot of the
distinction here is like isn't or saying
this is the case yeah but they ought to
be the case that it's not like why you
know it is what it is we kind of have to
accept that well dissing communism is
very easy just let us start keep coming
back at question time anyway sorry
Frances carry on me about that is that
because Che Guevara looks a lot better
on a t-shirt
he was cool you know you can't you can't
deny and if you wanted to if you wanted
to be the the resistance to lenity the
imperialist Americans then he was a good
symbol of resistance you know what
people didn't like him we live in Cuba
he kill a lot of people with his own
hand
yes it's some interesting opinions on
black people things like that but if you
are a middle-class kid who didn't like
the Vietnam War well easy here
absolutely and we're talking now about
civil liberties and actually the
government has taken a lot of our civil
liberties away and you could argue that
absolutely there's a right to do it and
there's a reason to do it but there is
also a precedent being set where
sometimes the government takes away
certain liberties and after the problem
has passed they're not so King to give
them back do you think that what we're
gonna see
after Corona has gone we're gonna see a
real struggle to get certain liberties
given back to us
well that's the fear I believe that
there was a specific time frame there
two years two years yeah so that
hopefully will we'll be as honored as we
expect it to be because the last thing I
want to have to do is fight a revolution
against the tyrannical government I
don't want I'm happy I don't want to
have to get barricades and shooted
soldiers I don't have to do that you
know we could do a rocky montage getting
me everyone's gonna have to do it if
that's the case it's like it's not just
me but the the the the thing that is
worrying them is me what I don't want to
downplay the danger of Corona man the
corona virus but the the fatality rate
is very low when like I mean and every
day it's getting lower and lower and
lower because the the number of people
being tested in the number of fatalities
is not necessarily congruent with the
number of people who have the disease
and the number of fatalities so every
day the number of fatalities actually
becomes a smaller percentage of people
who are tested for and so it could be
that this such a massive overreaction
and look I'm not saying there aren't
problems there are obviously problems
and obviously shutting things down as a
way of preventing it from reaching the
the worst-case scenario but I do think
that will be a theory that is considered
after this is all over
did we overreact did we allow the
government to have powers that we
actually don't want the government's
have and this was something that was
considered in retrospectively with the
Patriot Act and still people are not
happy with the powers that the American
government gave itself I guess only time
will tell but I'm really hoping that
cooler heads will prevail and people who
actually care about the integrity of the
system all you know in the future say
okay well no this this actually you know
this was a mistake or you know whatever
it contends out to be I'm not gonna make
a prediction but like you know if if it
turns out this was on this ferry this
should become understood you know we
shouldn't just jump just because media
environment is panicky I mean watching
Piers Morgan harm on on Twitter it's
like piers shut up right you were a fat
idiot you are not a doctor they are
taking advice from the best of you know
experts in this in the world and peers
moms like do this do that I don't kill
you saw on Twitter me I just don't care
like shut up and now leading to a
question that I particularly wanted to
ask you in that do you think part of
this hysteria comes from the media the
mainstream media hyping this up because
you know this is a chance for them to
gain ground and you know reclaim some of
their lost news and listeners and
actually create the state of hysteria um
they they definitely have incentives to
do it I mean one of the things I don't
do in my video titles is put all caps
because that to me feels like hysteria
mongering you know it feels like
clickbait you know so if I just put my
my title is a normal sentence a normal
title is owed I give her an essay sort
of thing then I feel that I'm not being
hysterical and click baiting I realize
it's a very subjective that's just the
way I feel about it um but the media but
you can't deny there is an incentive to
do do that it probably does get more
views probably does get more complex and
in a media ecosystem where a bunch of
them are dying and act you know actively
failing and need fat traffic to justify
more investment and to advertisers you
can see why they would be jumping on
this and yeah I think it's entirely
unhelpful
mean Trump actually did dress down one
reporter who was hearing called him
yes fear-mongering and I agree I think
that this is why Boras and Trump have
been doing such a good job of just
acting calmly and saying that we're
doing what we can you know we're doing
our best rather than running around
screaming the skies falling and they're
all gonna die it's not very useful and I
think the problem like that I think the
reason that some Boras and Trump have
been pushed to this degree as well is I
think they really don't want to do this
I don't think they wanna shut down
because they I think they view their
success is hinging on a good economy and
obviously shouldn't have the country
means that's the end of the good economy
and I don't think anyone's gonna blame
them for that what choice do they have
but I think it was pressure that builds
up and it might it does become a kind of
echo chamber when they just hear
everyone around going oh god we're all
gonna die if we don't do X and so
naturally gonna feel compelled to have
to do something even if that might not
be the wisest thing but that's just
that's just human decision making for
you well the thing I would say and that
is I think one of the things that I've
noticed is all the people that we've had
on the show in the past scientists and
people like that they are all very much
of the opinion that if we don't take the
some of the drastic actions that we're
taking now we will end up in a situation
where because of the the peak we get
over the capacity of the health system
to be able to deal with it and then you
end up with a lot of people dying who
would not have died otherwise and in
fact they may not even die of the corona
virus they may die simply because they
didn't have access to an intensive care
beds because that was taken up by
somebody who's it's like this thing now
with is actually half of the ICU beds in
this country are taken up by people
under 50 and most of them weren't died
from it right but they're taking up the
bed and the will cont there will come a
point if the infection keeps spreading
the older people who are essentially
well okay they're probably not going to
make it anyway they never get a chance
to even have their life potentially
saved simply because all the beds are
taken up so I do think that we do have
to take it seriously particularly as I
say the people who know what they don't
like you're saying I didn't mean to
imply that we shouldn't take it
seriously
absolutely should i I there is there is
a historical precedent though of experts
overestimating things this is like this
is one of the problem with the climate
debate is that though we've got a
prediction we're all gonna die in 12
days yeah but I'm actually old enough to
remember all of the other predictions
that we were gonna die in 12 years and
we didn't you know Al Gore by this point
we'd have no ice caps it's like he was
full of [ __ ] you know it's it's it's not
it's not that they aren't brilliant and
it's not they're an expert from the
field obviously it's just the world is a
massively complex place and I'm not
saying that I'm the one who understands
disease I can just admit that you know
we have to look at the precedents well
global warming is a totally different
thing it's much more complicated I think
you're absolutely right though mate cuz
I remember when I was at school I think
by this point we're supposed to run out
of oil 20 years ago run out of coal
pretty much now and then blah blah blah
so now I take your point but I think
epidemics are slightly different and
that's proof you never trust a Soviet
education system mate I actually went to
school in Britain made for my son you've
just slammed the British education
system yourself made like you look like
a good self-hating Brit anyway I'm
moving on slightly come what do you
think as we look at Frances drink his I
don't know white the screen is still on
Frances this is completely I'm gonna
change this I can't handling this is
censorship total [ __ ] rupture
exactly we must shut it down to the
gulag Lille for drinking from the wrong
mug but what we started talking about
the culture war and I want to come back
to because I wonder what you think as
someone who talks about this a lot and
who sees a lot of this stuff and it does
a lot of analysis on it what do you
think the impact will be like I've been
way too naive on all this stuff like
after last election I was like okay
finally that the idiots are gonna
realize but no one actually likes them
no one shares a super points of view and
actually we can have a proper political
debate by the stuff that matters didn't
really happen
do you think that as a result of this
some of the work stuff is gonna fall
away and we're all gonna we can actually
talk about stuff other than you know
idiots on University campuses shutting
down speakers because they don't believe
in 50 genders I don't I don't know I
don't I think the learning be a
temporary respite if we get it because
it won't it won't change the fundamental
contention that they have a different
definition of equality to everyone else
and while they pursue that definition of
equality we'll never be able to come to
a resolution because they'll continually
ask for things that aren't in our
definition of equality like I would I
would say the most reasonable people
would define equality as a quality of
treatment equality under the law so one
rule for all right and that's that's
it's very ancient actually that's a very
ancient idea in English culture it
hasn't always been applicable obviously
or applied but it's it's a ancient idea
that you like that's a form of equality
as say if you know because we invert the
idea of personal sovereignty I said okay
well if every man is going to be treated
like sovereign then every man has to be
treated under the same rule right the
law has to be consistent among the more
and so that's that's easy for us to then
define what is and is not equality
because we we are concerned with
procedural equality so if you know
yourself or Frances go up to I don't
know whatever I'm gonna use for an
example and you get treated differently
to me there you can say well that wasn't
equal because there's a demonstrable
inequality there and there's there's you
know it's an arbitrary thing but if we
end up going through the process and
there is an inequality at the end for
example it might be a test or something
you know yeah you might be way smarter
than me and we get different grades but
the test was if we were on equal footing
when we took the test the news about
factors that are beyond the control of
the person involved but the the the way
the woke left view equality is its
conceptual it's about I don't care about
the procedure they care that for example
men and like 15 percent more money in
aggregates than women do but in any time
you look at the procedure you can't find
any particular sexism because the
problem more
a quote-unquote problem this isn't a
problem but the the difference is made
up primarily by the fact that women just
work fewer hours a week than men they
don't do actually as much work as men do
by choice and it's there's nothing wrong
with that you know and so the this this
won't until we kind of square this
circle until we resolve why they're
asking for what they're asking for we
will never be able to effectively drive
them off because we have to be able to
nail them know if you want to use the
word equality it must mean procedural
equality not conceptual equality because
honestly I don't think they're really
being honest about why there are
inequalities at the end of our
procedures which I generally view to be
fairly fair I mean I think they're as
good as they're gonna get as far as I'm
concerned
sounds pretty racist to me there's a
question that I already wants and I want
to move it on towards globalization I'm
this constant thing you wanted to know I
want to talk a little bit more about the
culture war before though I mean think
globalization is one of definitely one
of the issues we'll talk about in a
second but in terms of the culture war I
guess I am kind of I've almost destroyed
my own argument because I remember like
two days ago there was an article in
Vice talking about how life-saving
transgender reassignment search is now
being delayed because of stupid people
who are dying here for the coronavirus
transphobic exactly and I just I don't
understand whether whether they're I
mean do people do you think people are
gonna stop reading vice because of the
stuff and eventually we will end up in a
position where maybe just like the
demand for that kind of content is gonna
fall because people really realize how
useless and pointless it is well I mean
if if people start encountering real
world problems then yeah this the demand
for this is definitely gonna go away
because I mean all of this sort of
highly introspective
mimimi view of the world you know my my
gender identity my this my that it's all
very much contingent on the fact
they aren't about staff the death will
get overrun by bandits and you know
there are gonna be no there are gonna be
no gender queers in foxholes when the
when the barbarian hordes come they give
me like all the men can protect us all
what's a man oh no no that's a man can
define man and define women and now it's
the men's job when they'll clamps on
that one very very quickly I think I be
yet its own until until there's a return
to normalcy I would think it'd be less
effective as an Augmented tactic but I
mean like I said it's not gonna go away
though it's not so all right what
Carla's saying is we're in business for
a nice little while yet all right well
this is the one of the iron is that of
all the stuff that you do and that we do
is we would love not to have to do
trigonometry yeah we would love to talk
about other stuff and I think you are
you are the same dude I'm exactly the
same I started a second channel just so
I could just do it anyway like I don't
you know I the the the the video is
about the what the thing the the way
that the society is changing because of
activism from the left I think is very
important I think it is important that
people are aware that there are things I
mean like because of the Conservative
government this is still all advancing
through local authorities because the
people in the position of local power
have been frankly tend to be quite pro
in sexuality and I don't know why you
know why that is but they just seem to
be and there's very little this appears
that conservatives can do which is
annoying because I mean they are the
government and they probably should be
like defunding some of this nonsense by
this point I mean like the whole the
whole thing is really annoying because a
lot of it is predicated on terms like
patriarchy you know and it's not okay
we'll define that it's like well the
rule of men that's okay will define what
a man is well a man is a social
construct it's like so what you're
saying you've got a circular argument
here where the concept of man defining
it created itself to create the
patriarchy that creates itself so
where's the origin point and that's
obvious nonsense
it's a
obvious a logical fallacy but if you if
you grounder the turn man is coming from
the biological expression of a human
being a male human being as an adult
human male and woman being adult human
female suddenly suddenly you don't find
yourself in this endless circle of
definitions you know self-referential
definition and so now you can actually
resolve what you're saying you've got
into the the origin the the method and
then the conclusion and you've reached
you've reached a sensible statement
unlike the way things being done now and
yet this is still going on and you know
these things are still being
proliferated so I did find it rather
frustrating I don't say and at some
point here's all gonna have to be undone
because frankly I mean you you can't
base a berry on something that is self
referential like that it's not gonna
work it's it's obviously not gonna
represent reality and that's the problem
so racist and transphobic the standard
thinking boss majority I would say
liberal sees the fact that we're an
interconnected planet and that means
that we can trade freely we can move
freely around the planet and this is
only beneficial to us until everybody
else but will the coronavirus change
that and the way that we perceive
borders and nation states and all the
rest of it well the coronavirus is
something of a nationalist a dream
actually isn't it's it's destroyed the
myth of globalization and the the
one-sided view of it the narrative that
it's only beneficial and there's nothing
bad that comes from it I mean for
example Italy has such a bad case of the
corona virus because they had loads of
Chinese workers working in factories in
Milan I didn't know that until after
this had happened but I looked into it
and it turns out that's true
and so this this came from movement of
workers from China and it's the same
with Iran Iran has a lot of movement
with China as well I'm surprised that
Africa major brands do but I would
imagine is something to do with
population density its Africa's got very
low population density anyway and
yeah the the the the great dream of the
Schengen zone is over even Germany has
closed their borders if even Germany has
closed their borders then there must be
some truth to the statement the borders
work walls work you know preventing
people from crossing a thing will
prevent those problems from coming with
them that is true you know it's I'm not
saying we have to do this but um but I
think there is a case for addressing the
concept of immigration at this point
there has been a loss of immigration I
think a lot of there's been ideological
on the part of the governments you know
the the reason for opening up I mean
Tony Blair is alleged to have said he
just did it to rub the rights face and
diversity
okay now we're looking at global
pandemics and the collapse of supply
chains and manually once again
manufactured items okay maybe maybe we
should have been slightly more
self-reliant there is there is still
some value in the idea of self-reliance
you know it's not there's no value in
the idea of global trade and movement
and stuff like that there is but there
is there is there are good parts and bad
parts of both and I think that a
sensible compromise between the two
would be at least a step forward
absolutely and that's really it's a
really important conversation one which
has obviously taken a backseat with
everything that's happening now because
one of the things that I thought was
very strange is that you know Boris is a
liberal Tory so what what really
happened after the last election is he
went yeah points based immigration
system except under that new immigration
system actually I think a lot of the
people who've been calling for
immigration to be reduced were very
likely to be disappointed by the outcome
because the way that system was
calibrated you probably were going to
end up with the same or if not more
immigration right so yeah it's hard to
know he's like we're gonna put the
points grace based immigration system
and then suddenly everyone's got to
close their borders and no one can
travel right did would it work we don't
know yeah no I think I think this is the
thing is I think at least we now at the
point we're having conversation where
you know as you talked about we need to
compromise you're not saying shut the
borders permanent they never let another
foreigner
in all right that's never been your
position but what you are saying is we
need to look at a sensible way of
managing immigration and we need to
check who comes in and it said one of
the funniest scenes to me actually about
this whole thing was and as you know I'm
not a UK fan or or even a Faraj time
particularly but one of the things that
got him criticized the most during the
breaks a referendum was him saying that
we should check whether people have
lethal diseases before they come into
the country do you remember yeah
what why wouldn't we do that you know
yeah this is what I mean about like that
there is I mean it's just prudence isn't
it it's just common sense it's just
sensible to be able to say look if we're
gonna have people come in we have to
have certain standards and you know to
make sure that obvious problems that
could occur like pandemics can be
mitigated to the best of our ability
it's just seems sensible and but I think
so can we we talk about the gropers know
shutting you down talk about the gropers
yeah because I was watching this and
like you know their war with you you're
a YouTube channel what do you go to war
but anyway so these seem to me white
nationalist
as far as I can tell yeah and so thank
you and let's just define that as well
so we know who these people are we know
where the telegram channels are they're
they're people who send each other
swastikas on ironically all this can't
they're neo-nazis let's call it yeah
well yeah yeah I mean I've I've been
I've been talking to a few of them and
it's weird that so many of them love
Hitler and hate Churchill I'm like and
they're like yeah we're British
nationalist some like okay there's a
loggia for the Nazi regime for British
nationalist but okay so that I'll just
call them white nationalists right yeah
I think that's the most neutral term I
can give them there
nationalists for white race in the white
race but the the thing like demanding
that you talk about their pet subject I
found interesting because like we you
don't have to and trigonometry isn't the
gatekeeper to the you know to the to the
rest of the country and this you know if
only it just seems like such a straight
thing and then like a bunch of them like
oh we're gonna do it to you and a bunch
of the posted 14 in my chat when I was
like when I'm like this is not rising up
lads right this is like when they were
phoning up Mike Graham and saying Mike
what about demographics because there is
a fundamental truth about the random
mass immigration is going to cause
demographic change in the United Kingdom
absolutely yeah no one can deny that
it's 100 century the numbers are in you
know the next census in London
especially in in Birmingham they're
gonna be eye-opening and I think after
more than 20 years of mass emigration I
think the British people like just
generally I mean that they've always
been very skeptical about mass
immigration they still are so I think
it's fair for them to a certain some say
well look we just like less you know
we're gonna we're not gonna torture
immigrants or something I'm gonna chuck
them off the cliffs of Dover but we just
you know when someone says can I move to
Britain we'll just say sorry we're not
allowing new people to move here at the
moment I don't think that anyone's
rights are violated I don't think anyone
gets hurt you know nothing happens I
think that's fair I think that's a
reasonable thing to do and yet these guy
he's a friendly like the white race is
gonna die in like you know let's assume
everyone agreed with you right but you
you if you want to you know move the
needle on anything and I think it is
reasonable to reduce immigration I don't
I'm not interested in kicking out every
foreigner there's over stepped foot in
the country but it days may I have pre
shared that it's a reasonable request
and framing in such unreasonable terms
you know we want to reduce immigration
also Hitler did nothing wrong then the
Holocaust didn't happen but it should
have done he's like yeah I mean I'm I'm
someone who wants immigration reduced
and I'm not a white nationalist and as
far as I'm concerned the group is just
seem to be a dead weight
so the
cause of reducing immigration all right
they make reasonable people look really
really bad because they are coming at it
from the completely the wrong hand see
the thing is that like all of us would
agree that immigration needs to be
reduced but and I I am a fierce critic
of Blair's immigration policy even one
of the reasons is that I think letting
so many people in such a period of time
prevented integration and then any
backlash that happens as a consequence
of that is going to be targeted at
people like me who've actually done
their utmost to integrate right
absolutely mate but so that's the thing
but having people who are genuine
neo-nazis attach themselves to very
reasonable concerns the ordinary people
have and then coming to our channel and
so demanding that we have conversations
with their favorite neo-nazi right it's
really annoying isn't it it is but it's
quite funny in a way as well because
these people look so childish and I
don't think they realize how pathetic
they look you know yeah I saw I saw
Alastair Williams giving one of them a
grilling the other day hmm just saying
look at you you know you you don't look
like someone worth having a conversation
with them you know you know that that is
in some ways true so it's it's one of
those things where it's just like I just
I mean you know if they want to do
something useful phone up phone up James
O'Brien on LBC guys seriously seriously
is there anyone who deserves to have to
be you know constantly phoned up by
neo-nazis all the dope right I want to
listen to a random member of the public
who's not a lunatic I won't change
O'Brien to literally have to go through
these Nazis arguments day after day okay
step by step by step so every call is
enough sleep excurrent exhausted by I
just want to watch that that sounds like
primetime in steam that would be quite
funny but the solution to this which is
exactly this is my dad who married a
brown woman and produced a child who's
full on gammon so he can basically let's
get him to procreate we've all ethnic
minority people and we're just gonna
have people don't I mean I have never
man advocating for his doctor shadow
group shagged around [ __ ] hell [ __ ]
but but actually one of the things that
I find quite interesting karl is that
the tactics of these people they are
exactly what antifa do it's quite
incredible and and they're claiming just
like ante for claims that they're
exercising their free speech one they
shut down conversations this is exactly
what these people do they flood a chat
room so no one else can talk and they
claim that this is about free speech
well it's a tactic and it's only because
it seems to be effective in the you know
in the local my areas and in that chat
but it's it's because there were
intention and the thing is like it's not
unfair it's not unfair to worry about
the I mean like when John Cleese said
London isn't an English city I'm not
from London and I agree with it you know
if you remember I defended him at the
time right so it's not like you
absolutely yeah yeah that's exactly
that's this that's why I'm baffled why
they think yeah trigonometry is the
problem right I mean like there are
loads of left this in The Guardian who
is screaming closing the borders is
racist and I don't care if we will die
from the coronavirus
I mean you guys are somehow the problem
is there Matt no like I said I called
James O'Brien because don't you think
it's a little bit of it's about ego
it's about celebration of the self it's
looking at results and if you target a
channel like us and we're not you know
we're growing but we're not a massive
channel we've only got 92 K sobs you can
see a real impact that your actions do
well if you target James O'Brien at LBC
your entities it's some massive its
gonna make no dent on them whatsoever
well I mean there and there are their
methods that you could you could make an
impact and it would require you know
like say like a hundred people every day
and since I was at home now they can do
this you know just just literally just
jam the phone lines with groper callers
every day and that that would have an
effect but like but James O'Brien
you know he's surely millions of
listeners LBC is a mainstream station
all the politicians go on it you know
and I'm not saying you're not mainstream
or successful or anything no we're not
but we're not mainstream I know so the
other thing is we're not at the bait
show like we've had you on the show we
don't debate you we talk to you we
interview we ask you some questions like
we've never had anyone on the show where
we
like we completely disagree with this
person about everything yeah you know
but it's like I I do agree with you what
you're saying is you know they I think
you know they are they they think
they've got a boner above target that
they can attack and they think that they
can do some damage this target you know
it might might they might do some damage
as well and but they've achieved nothing
you know they've gone no further to
their goal all they've done is made life
difficult for you but they actually
haven't let's be honest about it the
thing is when they give us lots of
comments I actually boost our engagement
level so nicely helps us so all I kind
of income from our patron and subscribe
star and also you know people see them
treating us unfairly and they wanna
support us so we donations have shot up
and everything else but it just it's
just it just seems like what my concern
with that is that these people are very
easy to associate with the people who
are more in line with your way of
thinking and then people like you get
tarnished by association with people
with who you completely despise and have
nothing in common with yeah it's it's
rather annoying being called all right
after I spent like a year of my life
actively driving them out of my spaces
right one of them one of the most
annoying things is when YouTube and
Facebook decided to deep platform people
who are all right you know like content
creators who own the idea and own the
phrase and own the movement because
that's you know they could congregate
that so their their comment sections
would be filled with all trite comments
and you know what I'm talking about and
as soon as these people at the platforms
well they still want to talk about the
same subjects now they're coming to like
York chap my Chad thinks ideas might my
comment sections I'm just like god
damnit YouTube you know I didn't want
these people wasting my time with these
you know these things they then they're
not they're not sensible in my opinion
but some but yeah but basically I just
think that the group is should stop
being cowards and go off and do
something useful for once but I don't
think they will
now and where do you stand on the issue
of censorship with these particular
people so a lot of them time they get
like you said have their YouTube channel
taken down do you think that YouTube
should be a sort of truly free speech
platform were you allowed to say
anything no matter how awful vile
or do you think there should be limits
within that well I mean nationally there
should be limits like you know threats
and Simon things like that you know and
and open harassment you know I can see
why that would be something that would
be something YouTube would want to
forbid I mean let's be fair YouTube is
way beyond that
oh yeah is really bad and they just take
it you know they took a few months ago
they just took down a spate of channels
and these channels you know hadn't done
anything to violate the guidelines they
weren't in violation of any of the
policies it was just one day take them
down I mean I got my channel my account
daily channel demonetised
out of the blue and YouTube told me that
was for harassment okay who did IRS each
they couldn't they none of I didn't get
strike none of my videos no strikes so
normally you you get a strike on a video
so they take that video down and get
straight for her you know whatever
Community Guidelines they get breached
but I didn't get any strikes I've I've
done nothing they can't tie a mail them
and I got some responses and they
couldn't tell me what video that they
were criticizing what that even said and
yet they were doing anyway and so really
feels like essentially they're looking
at the approaching November election in
America and you know clearing the field
I think but the ads it's it's quite
annoying how the gang so the noose is
getting quite tight it is man that
YouTube YouTube really should relax this
somewhat I really think so hmm no I was
just gonna say that the we talked about
this when we had some of our video to
monetize then you had me on your show
they're actually one of the things that
happens is you end up in a position
where they do monetize you but they
still run ads on your [ __ ] videos
yeah yeah that's I in fact those common
this morning I woke up this morning I
was just you know checking saved my
channel still there which is my day now
you know again have they delete my
channel yet
one of the first comments I saw was
someone said there were eight mid-roll
adverts on this video and I'm like oh
yeah you know I think one is enough but
eight apparent you know I don't see a
penny of that so it's like Christ
it's what taking advantage no I mean
it's really felt you know it's quite
frustrating and I don't I really wish
YouTube wouldn't be so I I mean I don't
say abusive but it is a kind of form of
abuse to continually treat people like
this they treat their own content
craters like with the enemy because
we're not Silicon Valley progressives as
I do bad luck but most people are not
Silicon Valley it progresses you know
that doesn't make them bad or bigoted
that just means they're not radical
leftist from California and isn't the
problem as well as that they've
effectively got a monopoly this is
really if you want to do this type of
content this is the only platform you
can do it on yeah yeah I saying that
right um Alex Jones dare I bring them up
as a site called band dot video which
gets privately good numbers and the
hundreds of thousands on a lot of their
videos so I think that some essentially
all of this sonship and there are lots
it's not just Alex Jones on it but he
created the platform together we see
there are lots of people who have
otherwise been censored on there and it
you know it's not it's not like you know
far-right sort of like you know neo-nazi
or anything like that
it's libertarian that's what you know
that's the sort way it is and so you get
like um you know the wasn't in Caitlin
Bennett's the gun girl who goes around
the campuses interviewing students and
things like that is people like that you
know people who will be who will
willfully miss gender for example and
that's considered a high crime now you
know whereas you know to us or
libertarian conservatives they don't
think about that at all it doesn't even
register on their moral compass you know
I think it is a bit unfair to have
sprung these kind of new standards on
them because it is very ideological you
know if you if you are a biological
essentialist shall we say then you are
completely and ideologically locked out
from entire spheres of engagement my on
Twitter I mean I know some like zubi
for example are brands uber yeah yes
exactly yeah okay dude spend it like a
suspension it's like come on
that's ridiculous I mean you know it is
just it goes on and it will continue
going on and but it does look like there
might be options there might be well
there's a problem with some of these
platforms in that you know if they
suspend and then they these people go on
to other platforms and what you're
creating is an entire subculture and
that what happens is these people end up
radicalizing themselves yeah that's
that's absolutely true and I mean Christ
this is quoting my last Telegraph piece
by the way thanks Maya well it's
completely true like lately it seems to
be forgotten that the way to Deer addict
lies someone is exposure to something
and they you know if you want if you
want the the old rights and hate brown
people less then they you know they you
you would want them to speak to these
people and understand they are human too
you know they have their own concerns
and cares and they're not insensitive to
the necessary to the concerns of the you
know either side and there doesn't have
to be this giant chasm but if you if you
just persecute someone say right you
know we're watching you and then we get
to platform you I'm gonna stigmatize you
then because in no way D converting
anyone that's know what no one was like
well I was a Nazi until I got the
platform now I was like you know what
that's right the Jews don't control the
leave there we go you know look look
this guy with the Jewish surname we
wrote an article about me and then I got
the platform there we go it's the Jews
his confirmation it confirms everything
that they are deeply and trusting deeper
into their beliefs it's the worst thing
to do what you should have I mean like
on questions I'm the other day there was
a lady who wanted to stop mass
immigration she just looked like a
regular world class lady to me a little
freaked out okay no god this is
far-right propaganda it's like dude this
is the majority of the opinion opinion
of the country you know if she's too
controversial then that I don't know
what we're gonna do you know you've
narrowed the range of debate to a very
very narrow position and yeah it was
like Baroness Warsi and her Labor MP you
were petitioning the BBC to make sure
that they couldn't have those sort of
opinions on again it's like look I think
the BBC has a duty if we all have to pay
for it they have a duty to put those
people on and if there
wrong we'll talk about it I think with
that woman the issue probably might have
been I mean in a lot of these issues
it's look there's a kind of there's a
level of classism involved as well like
I think if she was a middle class person
then she'd phrased it differently I mean
I don't think by the way that the
majority of the people in this country
would subscribe to what that woman said
which was we must not do it all
immigration yeah it's too extreme yeah
you know in polling someone between 50
and 70 percent of people agree there's
been too much immigration yes all right
but that's my point like I think she
it's the way she phrased it and maybe
also an element of the extremist part of
the sentiment I'm not saying she's an
extremist I'm saying that way of
thinking is towards the extreme right I
don't think it's a it's a hard-line
position she's yeah right because I mean
she was a middle class person I think
she'd get a different response in my
point yeah yeah they would they wouldn't
nearly be so scornful of her yeah you
know dismissive and again as if as if
this is not a legitimate opinion it is
legitimate opinion you know it's it's
one of the things that mom really did
drive the brakes at referendum is
actually see how you look at the Lord
Ashcroft polls and immigration is a
problem we've had it for such a long
time and there are genuinely like the
like the reason I brought the group is
because they always got all demographics
demographics demographics well that's
true you know it is true the numbers are
in and on the on the birmingham council
website i found the other day that only
one-third of birmingham school children
are English the rest come from foreign
extraction so that's something that does
have to be talked about you know it's
it's irresponsible thing that can just
be stamped down you know because the the
real people on the ground the regular
person they can see the change this is
this is the point where these great this
Frances before before you ask your
question and our final question did the
point with them is that where do we go
from here right the reality is that as I
was saying massive opposition from me to
the blame aggression project but the
people are here now right and the only
way you can have a multi-ethnic
societies for us to have a common
identity which is fortunately one that
we have we can say that I can say that I
am British
and Frances can say that he's British
and you can say they're British and what
we actually mean by that is we have a
common set of values and identities
based around those shared values the
problem that we've had over the last 20
years is the far left has deliberately
attempted to destroy that identity and
to say there's no such thing as British
identity there's no such thing as
British values and what that leaves us
well if there's no identity then we all
retreat into our ethnicity yeah that's
that's a really great way frame yeah and
they've been very clever about it as
well because normally when when called
to account for one's own value system
and culture you don't have to write on a
day-to-day basis it's a lot of a lot of
it is kind of like you know it when you
see it right like regardless of where
Francis says his parents are from I hear
a Londoner right right I hear a Brits
you know that's so there's no question
of it so it's you know a lot of the time
but if I tell her I said Francis what's
a British person you know God I don't
know you know I mean like you know and
then you get like John Major's answer
which is cricket on a green and a summer
day you know way saying is that's
something that was uniquely British you
know that only really happens in Britain
no you don't get the same atmosphere in
say Pakistan when they're playing
cricket it's a different thing you know
and so it's essentially the the post
modernists have been very very
aggressive on this point a very clever
about it because it requires you to sort
of find the Maxim's upon which the thing
is founded and I think that if some
would say again what is what does it
mean to be British then I think that the
the most important thing we could say
isn't the highest values fairness you
know the most important thing the
British values fairness above all things
you know like it really doesn't matter
what else it is I think it's always
filtered through a prism of fairness and
there's there are a lot of aspects to
this as well I won't go into now but
like it is this sort of shared value but
it's also the characteristics of the
thing right as in you know we we talk
about the weather
you know we dress and suits we wear you
know we have a Union Jack we have red
telephone boxes and buses you know and
and so when if you look at like the
Falkland Islands
my dad served in Father Knows clued in
the RAF you see a picture of it and
interpreter as well right
Gibraltar looks like Britain with
countries that's it you know it's and
Joe and the Falkland Islands look like
Britain with walruses on the beaches you
know but you know it's the same sort of
sign format the same style of building
the same you know the the same
atmosphere that the the cultural
signifiers of just the country and and I
imagine the behavior of the people is
also similar this is the point very but
that's really the point is if people
behave in similar ways that's what
culture is it's not about your skin
colour red that's the point culture is
the thing that people do yes pression of
it yeah but what the left to me have
done in particularly that aspect is they
criticized the sort of British state and
Paul the thing they say is you know it's
built on the blood of slavery it's a
shame and it's a disgrace and you know
it's all the rest of it and then to
therefore identify as British means that
you therefore sort of born almost into a
quite an original sin you were born into
the shame and to the evils of your
forebears regardless of what they did
describe to that I mean I I personally
don't ascribe to that myself I think
that people should be judged on their
individual merits yeah but they there is
there is a way of looking at it where
they're not necessarily wrong I mean if
you if you want to have a continuity of
identity and feel that you have
something in common as a descendant of
people who lived in the past I mean and
you are clean there is a continuity so
you if you if you grow up with cultural
values that are British well these are
cultural values that have been inherited
and developed and you know maybe
improves or beg written degraded but
it's in there's a continuity a
consequence of what came before and but
anyone who wants to stigmatize something
as being all bad and no in no way good
that's a person who I think is trying to
get that one over on you to be honest
because we know it's that's not true I
mean the the British Empire one of the
listen to Churchill speak
the other day and he was speaking
against Nazi Germany saying look Nazi
Germany stands against everything the
British Empire stands for and by the
definition they've given you mean what
the hell would the British Empire stand
for you know slavery and being
imperialism but that wasn't how they
thought of themselves you know they
thought themselves as actually in many
ways liberating the world from things
that are terrible and in many ways they
did I mean there was the British Empire
that ended the slave trade and ended
slavery around the world
it wasn't the Germans it wasn't you know
the Chinese or anyone else you know we
we actively spent our blood and treasure
on a moral mission that was against re
cummock interest because it was the
right thing to do and there you get
let's not say the Britain didn't do
anything wrong yes we did you know for
everyone everyone is you know so the way
the way I look at this is morality as a
technology right morality is not
something that came fully formed from
the ether that we just chose to ignore
right and so the invention of slavery
was actually a moral innovation because
prior to that was just murder and so
instead the this you know the conquerors
well we can make them far more crops
whatever not not optimal obviously
terrible situation but it's probably
better than having your head karf right
and you know and you get this kind of
long development of morality and the
only reason that we would want to that I
mean it was for moral reasons that
Britain ended the slave trade because
the the the British have never really
tolerated slavery and they had it in
Britain really it was William the
conquerer outlawed the slave trade not
for any altruistic reasons but just
because he thought he could make more
money he thought if we could catch
slavers and he could just take their
money and that was it you know so it was
it was a source of revenue but that in
grains in the society that slavery is
just a normal thing and then you know we
we assay it was England that eventually
created the kind of this or liberal
spirit of freedom the idea of personal
freedom that we have and so it was
natural that it was going to be England
that said no we're not having the slave
trade actually this is actually because
I mean like there was some there was a
petition that was suddenly 30,000
signatures a mile long
that the women of England stitched
together got signs stitched together and
delivered to Parliament you can view it
on the parliamentary website you know
and it's it's you know this is a lot of
work you know and that's a lot of
feeling and depth of feeling behind it
and so when someone says all the British
Empire is nothing but evil well I
disagree and contemporaneously who would
you have preferred to be in charge of
the world well this is this is this is
the thing this is the thing that people
always forget I'll say this before we
ask you our last question is that
everything exists in comparison right
yes so if you are saying that the
British Empire was this evil slave
owning Empire then there's an element of
truth to that because that's what it was
it invaded other countries it took
people as slaves
blah blah blah but what we see around
the world today is that there are places
in the world where there's more slavery
than we've ever had and are we saying
that those people have they been in our
place have they won that battle of
civilizations they wouldn't have had
slaves of course they would and they did
right so it's all about yes okay we've
got a reflect on our past and learn from
it but do we need to continually be
ourselves a provider I don't I really
don't think so in in the real slavery we
did learn oh yeah so it would be it
would be ridiculous to reject you know
the positive identity of being British
on the back of slavery it's like no this
is one of our greatest moral
contributions to humanity like slavery
is a scourge that played every society
from the dawn of recorded history and
the British like actually that's enough
and and we're supposed to I mean like in
effort for any anyone who had impugn us
on this like we've done a lot wrong but
that's not one of those things you know
that's something that we can be proud of
and I think we should be proud of and
you're right you're absolutely right
like for example the Islamic empires
didn't in slavery no the Chinese didn't
in slavery
you know the Aztecs and all these other
you know but it came from a particular
kind of philosophy that was developed in
England and was fortunate enough to be
at the helm of world power when it came
to the time where it could be ended and
we did so we should we should we should
be able to hold on to that like a rock
in the face of these kind of attacks
they know
very few of the countries are interested
in doing what Britain did and we did it
even the cost I mean we we only finished
paying off the debts that we incurred by
ending the slave trade in 2014 right we
I holy [ __ ]
I'm not joking hey I want my money black
my Russian ancestors had nothing to do
with this [ __ ] my surname is Benjamin
right now because I am of any Jewish
descent but because on my father's side
my grandfather came from santolina some
Halina was a slave island off the coast
like near africa and it was in 1792 that
the slave trade was prohibited there I
don't know why it was earlier and
everywhere else actually but for
something that was but me the the reason
I say this is because at some point in
my father's lineage he you know what my
ancestors will have been slaves and I
know this because what happens upon
manumission is that you take the surname
of the slate the first name of the slave
owner as the surname of the monument
it's slave so at some point in my
father's lineage at Syene a hundred
years ago someone called benjamin
something will have had slaves and my
family would have been part of their sex
and yet I have finished paying for
slaves my money there's my reparations
you know I mean but but the thing is
like it's it gets silly you can't fix
history I'm a you an honorary Jew and
hence welcome target for the diapers
here they come sort of liberal comedians
who say things like you know you know
Britain is you know built on the blood
of slavery and they they all go into it
and then you see them next week Oh
anyway guys really looking forward to my
kitchen - bye see you later device like
an 80% indentured servitude yeah we're
running out of time we've done an hour
and 15 minutes Carl thank you so much
for coming back it's always a pleasure
to speak with you we're gonna hear you
with our last questions what's the one
thing that we're not talking about as a
society that we really need to be the
2021 census that's that's the thing it's
it's this is really going to be the
eye-opener because all of the all the
data on population
graphics we have comes from the 2011 one
apart from like some local ones which
sway like the Birmingham schoolchildren
Ragab I don't know what the population
of Birmingham looks like because we
don't have that information yet census
has done and the 2021 census is going to
be the census where people like Nigel
fries will be proven right basically and
inna there was a problem with mass
emigration after ten years of it it
probably does need to change and it's
it's looming on the horizon and it's
getting closer and closer and it'll be
it'll be the subject of quite fiery
debate I have no doubts or thank you
very much for coming on Carl and we'll
see you again everybody we've got
another episode we'll releasing on
Sunday with dr. David Starkey so
exciting stuff but thanks so much for
coming yeah he's crazy so that that's
coming very soon as we've told you
during this time of corona we're gonna
be putting out a piece of content pretty
much every day so we'll see you tomorrow
take care and goodbye see you guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word